it's tragic what's happened i think it's
unnecessary i think we made a serious
mistake in doing this in this way it's
not just about the afghan people it's
about us and our security because you've
now got this group back in charge of
afghanistan
they will give um protection and sucker
to al-qaeda
you've got isis already
in the country trying to operate at the
same time
you know
you look around the world
and the only people really cheering this
decision are the people hostile to
western interests
former british prime minister tony blair
talking about the situation currently in
afghanistan over the weekend you may
have seen on fox news sunday current
secretary of state
tony blinken talking to chris wallace
asked about the contradictory statements
of president biden in his various press
conferences
does the president not know what's going
on
this is an incredibly
emotional time uh for for many of us the
president said al qaeda is gone it's not
gone the president said he's not heard
any criticism
from the allies there's been a lot of
criticism from the allies words matter
and the words of the president
matter most chris all i can tell you is
what what i've heard and again
this is a powerfully emotional time for
a lot of allies and partners as it is
for me as it is for us
let's bring in our panel guy benson
political editor townhall.com host of
the guy benson show on fox news radio
harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman ceo of empowerment inclusion
capital and trey gowdy former
congressman from south carolina trey i
was struck by that answer by the
secretary of state that it was an
emotional time for all of us
not answered specifically about the
president's statements back and forth
it's a real emotional time for the
americans on the outside of that taliban
ring
yeah if tony blinken thinks his emotion
will be on chris wallace's show try
hanging on to the wheel of of an
airplane that's taken off i mean i i
but you know what bret the only thing
that's been worse than the policy
the execution of the policy has been the
ex
explanation from from the bite
administration they can't agree on
whether al qaeda is still there or not
they can't agree whether the airport
is safe and they can't agree on whether
or not biden was given different
military advice i mean they're feckless
and the best debates in washington right
now are the ones taking place within the
bible administration it's quite
something to see harold um this exchange
with peter ducey today about stranded
americans also raised some eyebrows take
a listen
most of the criticism is not of leaving
afghanistan it's the way that he has
ordered it to happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home
all right harold clearly there are
americans who feel stranded and they
haven't been able to get to the airport
we just have to stipulate that and there
are eight days until this
deadline that the president apparently
is deciding on on august 31st
so what about that
first it's good to be with you i think
the eight days from now that that's what
worries and concerns me uh the most and
we can parse words and i know and like
shinsaki
i do think there are americans that that
are are stranded there at least they
feel like they are stranded uh the
context i agree with i agree as i often
do i agree with trade that the the we
all wanted to exit or many wanted to
exit but the execution is the problem
serious-minded people have to be willing
to set aside the politics here for a
moment and let's focus on democrat and
republican
what resources will be needed if the
taliban's to be believed that they want
us out before the 31st and aren't aren't
for extending the deadline
what are we prepared to do i think the
president's got to think long and hard
about that
and be ready to articulate that to the
country i listened to prime minister
blair the former prime minister and i
like him too but he also was part of an
effort that diverted resources under
president bush he agreed to to from from
afghanistan's counterterrorism efforts
to go to war with iraq which i think
history will prove will prove probably
was a mistake i voted for that war based
on what was told to me in the congress
there's no doubt occupying forces in
afghanistan don't work alexander the
great suffered his only defeat there and
obviously the russians did now that
gives no excuse for why this president
and i would argue his predecessor
couldn't get a better deal to get the
extraction of not only americans out but
our afghan allies but unfortunately for
president president biden it's on his
watch now and as he shared the other day
the buck starts with him and they're
going to have to have a better plan
if it extends beyond august 31st to get
americans out of afghanistan safely and
the thought now guys that this decision
has to be made pretty quickly if it is
going to be a deadline of august 31st in
the next 24 hours they need to come up
with yes that is or no that isn't the
taliban says that's a red line for them
why we as the greatest military in the
world
care about that i don't know uh your
thoughts
not only care about it it seems like in
some ways we're paralyzed or beholden to
it which is sort of a shocking turn of
events now you're right that decision
has to be made very soon part of the
problem here brett is it seems like many
decisions involving this withdrawal
should have been made weeks or months
sooner than they actually were and going
back to that clip of jen saki today in
that exchange with peter ducey i have
been mystified repeatedly on the policy
and the messaging choices of this
administration on this issue and the
withdrawal in particular
i was particularly mystified
by her choice the white house press
secretary's decision that she made
to pick a fight on parsing the word
stranded
involving thousands of americans and
allies who are definitionally stranded
right now they didn't say abandoned
peter didn't use that word abandoned
forever right now they are stranded
there is example after example pouring
in from people americans and otherwise
who feel and are stranded and this is
once again it going it goes back to the
point
that chris wallace was hammering on the
the canyon between the rhetoric of the
administration and the reality on the
ground and they stepped in it again
today yeah and quickly i mean politics
is a part of this it's always a part of
anything in washington tray the house
minority leader kevin mccarthy tweets
out according to president biden
americans can easily get to the airport
in kabul they can't al qaeda is no
longer in afghanistan they are the
border is secure it isn't republicans
i mean they have to want the the
solution but obviously they're taking
this moment to say this is screwed up
i think part of what kevin's doing there
is just reminding the media how
fascinated they were with biden's
experience and this whole america's back
and the reality is
america's leaving in the taliban is back
and my guess is mccarthy was poking more
at the media than he was at biden hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else